[Música]
hola
espero que se la estén pasando muy bien
me llamo napoleón
pero no crean ustedes que estudia
historia por mi nombre
no esa no es la razón
un día al igual que todos ustedes
tuve que decidir que estudiar
y decidí que me gustaba la historia
pero el momento más difícil fue
comentárselos a mis papás
seguramente como comentó
ferrán
hasta ahora comprendo me puse nervioso
ansioso
sentía algo en las piernas pero
finalmente les comenté a mis papás que
quería estudiar historia
y como suele sucedernos a todos los que
estudiamos historia o alguna carrera de
ciencias sociales
la primera pregunta fue a qué te vas a
dedicar qué vas a hacer de qué vas a
vivir
y seguramente como suele suceder muchas
veces en la familia la preocupación
fundamental es tendrás posibilidades
económicas de vivir
de mantenerte de tener alguna vez una
familia
no supe qué decirles a mis papás en ese
momento
no supe decirles de qué se trataba la
historia
no supe explicarles exactamente qué
hacía un historiador
simplemente tome la decisión
y llegué a estudiar historia
pero aún en la escuela de historia no
supe en ese primer momento cuál era la
razón de estudiar historia un día
acompañado de algunos amigos nos
dirigimos a una ciudad cercana donde
había vestigios arqueológicos
y ayudados de una pala y un pico
empezamos a hacer lo que denominamos
exploraciones arqueológicas
y que creen
el maestro nos reprimió nos dijo que no
era posible que hiciéramos eso que antes
debíamos de haber pedido permiso porque
explorar algún sitio ameritaba ante todo
de un permiso oficial
y poco a poco fui comprendiendo que era
la historia y supe algo que hoy en día
me queda muy claro
entender el presente a través del pasado
ese es el punto central del historiador
a partir de una serie de documentos de
materiales de diversa naturaleza podemos
entender el pasado
encontrar las leyes y las relaciones
económicas políticas sociales
que le dan una explicación a esa
sociedad en la que vivimos
pero no se cree que es tan fácil
entender el pasado nos permite
reconstruir una serie de fenómenos
actuales y contemporáneos
no se crea tampoco que el historiador es
un ratón de biblioteca
así lo expresaba en algún momento un
amigo nuestro un reconocido historiador
luis gonzález y gonzález quien decía
mire napoleón todos creen que somos
ratones de biblioteca o ratones de
archivo según sea el caso
y efectivamente uno de los puntos
centrales es que los historiadores
leemos
leemos libros nos acercamos a los
acervos bibliográficos que por cierto
nuestra institución tiene excelentes
ejemplos de ello y hacer los antiguos
que son orgullo de esta institución
pero también vamos a los archivos
y en los archivos encontramos
expedientes viejos
expedientes que dejan ver a través del
polvo o la humedad que han pasado muchos
años tal vez siglos sin que alguien los
hubiera tomado en sus manos
y de esos documentos logramos extraer
datos importantes que nos permiten
entender cómo vivieron en otros tiempos
pero para hacerlo
tenemos que estudiar algo adicional
tenemos que estudiar la paleografía
porque los antiguos mexicanos no
escribían como lo hacemos nosotros
tenían una serie de abreviaturas y una
serie de elementos que estaban presentes
en su escritura que hoy debemos entender
a través de la paleografía
así que la historia se va complicando
poco a poco pero también en eso radica
el elemento más hermoso de la historia
el poder ir descubriendo poco a poco
esos documentos esas relaciones
identificar personajes
relaciones problemas movimientos la
historia es dinámica la historia es
dialéctica
así es la historia pero así es la vida
misma la vida misma es dialéctica
y algo más importante no crean que todos
los testimonios son escritos
cuántos de nosotros hemos platicado en
el seno familiar con nuestros abuelos
con nuestros tíos y entonces ellos nos
han platicado historias y eso son
testimonios orales
la historia pues se construye de
distintas maneras y mediante diferentes
testimonios
no es solamente sentarse y empezar a
leer y revisar un libro
y tal vez pedirle al maestro que nos
deje leer únicamente un capítulo no la
historia es más compleja
y la historia también tiene que ver con
la imaginación
si no tenemos imaginación no podremos
comprender cuál ha sido el desarrollo y
el devenir de la sociedad
tenemos que dejar volar la imaginación y
luego encontrar asidero en aquellas
fuentes
la historia por sí sola no explica toda
la problemática hoy en día el
historiador debe participar en proyectos
multidisciplinarios
en la medida en que nos podamos acercar
a los antropólogos a los sociólogos
a los filósofos a los biólogos ya muchos
otros que cultivan otras disciplinas
podremos encontrar entonces una
explicación integral de los problemas
que agobian a nuestra sociedad
por cierto les voy a comentar una
anécdota que recién me ha ocurrido
platicábamos sobre la multidisciplina en
la escuela de historia
y les pregunté a mis alumnos
y a qué se dedica la antropología
un joven levantó inmediatamente la mano
presto presuroso me dijo maestro estudia
los antros
me quedo claro entonces que debemos
hacer un esfuerzo por transmitir a
nuestros estudiantes lo que es la
historia lo que es la antropología
porque si no al rato estudiaremos en
otros confines de la ciudad
pero la historia también recurre a otros
documentos
las fotografías esas fotografías que
ustedes reiteradamente imprimen en su
celular o en algún otro dispositivo
también tienen una explicación
en esas fotografías se pueden advertir
no solamente los rostros los seres
humanos no se pueden advertir también
las clases sociales
alguna fotografía antigua recrea
una plaza
y en esa plaza bien ustedes
perfectamente definidos dos sectores
en la parte central se encuentra aquella
clase
económica y política detentora del poder
y en sus alrededores se encuentran la
gente común
eso forma parte de lo que nosotros
denominamos lectura de imagen
pero invitemos a los historiadores
también a que no se concreten única y
exclusivamente a leer un libro de
historia
lean literatura
la literatura nos permite recrear lo que
anteriormente decía la imaginación
el cine nos permite identificar una
serie de problemas que explican de mejor
manera cuál es el sentido del desarrollo
de una sociedad
el teatro y otro tipo de manifestaciones
artísticas forman parte también de ese
espectro al que nos tenemos que acercar
los historiadores
no sabía eso
cuando mis padres me preguntaron
y que estudia un historiador
y ya que te vas a dedicar napoleón
y a pesar de ello mis padres me apoyaron
me dijeron estudia lo que tú quieras
estudia lo con ahínco con entrega con
pasión estudia lo que quieras lo que te
guste
y lo hice y soy feliz soy feliz como
historiador y soy feliz también porque
comprendo buena parte de lo que ocurre a
mi alrededor
muchos años pasaron
antes de que un familiar me mostrara una
carta
y en esa carta mi padre le decía
napoleón nos acaba de decir que va a
estudiar historia
tengo miedo que va a ser napoleón
finalmente
aquí estoy
sólo quería decirles mi nombre es
napoleón
pero esa esa no fue la razón por la que
estudie historia
[Aplausos]